all right easy
uh where'd you grow up where are you
from originally
um originally I'm from a small town in
Rhode Island called Woonsocket
um I grew up there most of my early
childhood
I grew up in in and out of group homes
what's going on at home did you excuse
me what was going on with your parents
that they lost you
um uh my mom was married to my
stepfather not my real father
um
I grew up in an abusive home uh
physically and and mentally
uh my stepfather used to beat my mother
me and my mother on on a night tonight
basis
uh
um around the age of uh six or so I
was taken from my mother and put into a
orphanage where I grew up to about the
age of 11.
and then pretty much after that it was
just uh
growing up in and out of the system or
in the streets
how would you describe your childhood
with your with your foster home and your
your parents
um
childhood was uh
I didn't have it it wasn't silver spoons
in in wedding cakes you know
um definitely wasn't no rainbow as a
kitty cats either uh like I said I grew
up in a lot of group homes
um around the age of 13 I decided I
wasn't going to live in a group home
anymore
and I ran out to the streets and uh
I uh started Living on the streets
during the gang
um I am an active member
to this day uh
I um
it started out with uh selling drugs you
know
um selling drugs to whoever I didn't get
um back then it was crack cocaine
um and I used to sit back and laugh
about all the crackheads that would come
by and
you know oh look at them you can drink
these I had to do anything for a
crackless and I'd look at it in the palm
of my hand I'd be like the power of of
the essence of this white stuff that
just is so powerful you know and it
would grasps them to to smoke this stuff
and
um it's crazy you know
and I did that for a couple years until
I landed in juvenile hall
where
juvenile hall is where I actually was
jumped into
um
the game that I I'm active in it's uh I
am a member of the Gangster Disciples
um I was jumped in by six six guys and
um six older boys and that were of me
and uh
we call it the 66 with six you know you
it's uh six guys for 60 seconds
and unless you or you until you can hold
your own you can't hold your own anymore
basically so
um
after that you know I felt nobody loved
me no one cares so why should I I think
you know who gives a [__] right no I
don't care you don't care I don't care
let's do this
um
around the age of 15.
I um met my daughter's mother I actually
had my my I have two daughters they're
more I met their mother
just getting out of juvenile hall and um
you know I lied to her about my age I
told her I was 18 and and she said well
okay that's cool you know at least
you're over the age
and then um uh about I don't know maybe
a month and a half later three months
later
um I decided I was going to tell her the
truth that I was only 15 instead of 18
and she was like well I got something to
tell you and she's like I'm pregnant
and I was like oh
and I was like well I have something to
tell you I'm only 15. and she like kind
of fainted a little bit and
and uh you know
um
so I was like I was kind of proud of
myself you know here I was what I was
trying to do is I was trying not to be
like my father
um who I thought was nothing nobody in a
piece of [__] who would just abandoned
his wife and or his girlfriend or
whatever she my mother was to him and
his child because at this time I still
hadn't seen him or
hadn't
um met him in any type of shape or form
and uh
you know um
I thought you know living the family
life was was what it was you know and
and I did that for a few years a couple
years
um
I didn't know that at the time you know
still selling crack at the time uh that
things were about to go Whirlwind out of
control and just take a whole different
spin on on things like
because one of the one things I said
that I would never do is something that
I ended up doing and I was started
smoking crack cocaine
um I was just I was 16 years old and I
was I had been drinking all day long and
I've been snorting some cocaine and a
friend of mine was like Hey easy you
tried this before
I said man that's some crackhead [__]
you don't want to do that have you run
around here feeling like all these other
streams out here I'll never do that and
they was like No just try it man put it
on top of your weed put it in a blunt we
call them woolies Yo all right so you
know as I proceeded to go ahead and
smoke me a wooly and that was it so then
you know curiosity they say kills the
cat and that's exactly what happened so
I got curious as to well what happens if
you smoke it without the weed hmm and
I'll tell you what I found a brand new
love
um
this day I don't smoke crack anymore but
I tell you what I still love crack
because uh even though she did me dirty
and me she didn't put me in into places
where I never wanted to be and you know
she's just always been my mistress
you know uh
around the uh
right around the age of 18 no she's
about 17 I I hate me and my daughter's
mother we both hitched like to Florida
and uh
things just progressed to get progressed
to seemingly get worse after
day after day
um
one thing after another
it got to the point where
my daughter's mother
would uh
let me back up a little bit so first off
I knew I had a gift I have a gift of
looks and I'm not a bad looking guy I'm
not too my own horn or anything like
that but I know I can get women so that
was one of my things that I would do
when I was younger now not only
[Music]
from that aspect but I would use my
looks to get anything from anybody
anywhere you know what I mean
um especially women and I wasn't ashamed
to even do say hey you know what if the
dude likes me then you know let me see
what I can get of get what I can get out
of them you know what I mean it's this
is the way of the world nowadays you get
you get getting or you get got you know
um
so
from for many years I I played the crack
game I sold crack I smoke crack I I had
plenty of women me and my daughter's
mother we broke up she moved back to
Rhode Island
um I stayed in Florida in Tampa and I
had about two or three women that would
that I would uh hang out with and smoke
crack and make money and and they would
go out and do what they called tricks I
mean everybody's heard them tricked I'm
not saying anything that's not new
um
you know uh
the reality of the world didn't set in
until I was probably about 18 I'm just
turning 18 and I got picked up for my
first possession charge in the state of
Florida
and I caught four years probation in a
four-year suspended sentence
um
still I thought the world was owed me
something I thought that that you know
this can't be
um this can't be older that life is is
giving me so you know what all right I
got this for you suspended sentence but
you eat it on the chin you know
um so I've proceeded to have attitude
and
um
a chip on my shoulder I guess you would
say it was
um so Ron rerun I just before I turned
19 I caught my first prison bid in the
state of Florida
uh I won't lie being young and
everything
I cried when I was in by myself and
myself
you know but then when I hit the yard I
was like I had to put that Persona back
into the pocket
because the little kid wasn't there
anymore you know nowadays it was time to
grow up in in in do this prison term
that I had caught in Florida
um
so the judge looked at me and told me he
said uh
sir I've had you in this courtroom
several different times and I've given
you enough opportunities
so here's one I think you're gonna have
enough time to ponder on I sentenced you
to four years in a state of Florida
Penitentiary system
and
you know let me tell you something I I
see movies and I watch things and you
know you you see movies and you see what
they do in the movies they're like oh no
that's is that gonna happen to me is
someone gonna push me down and rape me
or whatever
you know yeah it's just some prison
systems are harder and tougher than the
others others yeah but um I'll tell you
what I fitted right in
the minute I hit the yard it was there
was a click of uh of my crew that
that
um they do you know they come and greet
you and then they help you whatever the
care package until you can get on your
feet and everything like that
you know and uh
I fit right in it was like it's like
it's like I wasn't even
I wasn't even off the streets I was just
in a whole different environment a new
environment of um
of uh
it felt like a different like a like a
time zone like a Twilight Zone you know
it was surreal
um
and then
you know
being in prison and waking up every day
and doing this and going out to work out
in the field and you know it just it
kind of put this thing into you like it
hardens you like you know why would I
why was I here why am I here you know I
didn't do anything wrong you know and um
I thought life was peaches and creams
because it was this is what I was showed
this is how I was grew I I was raised I
was raised to be
to dig like I said to get or get got you
know what I mean
um prison was fun up until probably the
first time I saw my first person get
stabbed
um we had been on the on the handball
court and there were some words exchange
between these two gentlemen on the Block
earlier that day and while we were
playing handball this gentleman came out
of nowhere and proceeded to stick the
guy in the neck three times
and it does nothing
more uh
not fun than being sprayed in the face
with warm blood you know and and it kind
of put me into a shock stage for a
minute like damn this is really
happening here you only see this [__] in
the movies you know what I mean
so um
yeah that
that day forward I kind of um
kind of washed my words because I
remember when I first got on the yard
and I I told someone I told this
old-timer he was he had been down for
about 22 years and I said you know what
man he said something to me and I was
like you know [__] you suck my dick and
then like he looked at me like
crazy and my homeboy come up to me he
said hey man
you know who that is man I said I was
like I don't give a [__] he's like well
you should because you're lucky you're
not being airlifted out of here
you know and they broke down the prison
etiquettes of what to say to another man
and what not to say to another man and
then to this day forward even though I'm
not in prison anymore I still live to
those ethics and codes there's three
things you don't never tell another man
you don't even tell a man you don't call
a man a [__] a punk and you never tell
a man to suck your dick unless you're
ready to fight
you know I'm saying I had to learn that
the hallway and then later on that that
that evening I went up to the to the old
timer and I apologized to him and he
told me he said look at me young blood
he said 15 years ago you'd be airlifted
out of here and your mom would be
writing sending flowers to your grave
and then that's when I learned the
prison etiquette so the three things you
don't say to a man in prison
um you know
the day of the day for me to get out um
I remember the day I got out of prison
in the State of Florida it was November
3rd of 2000
and one
um it was just after 9 11.
um and the world was totally shocked by
The Towers falling down and and
everything and
it was crazy because like um when I hit
New York because I took a bus from
Florida back to Rhode Island
um I hit New York and it was like
everything was blocked off there was no
way you can really go and it was just
like crazy as hell and and when you get
out of prison in the State of Florida
they give you a bus ticket and 200 cash
and a pair of clothes uh uh little
flip-flop shoes and a pair of khaki
pants with a blue shirt
so everybody knows you just got out of
prison
um now when I got out of prison I felt
that there was a whole error of me
that I missed
you know I felt like I was being a child
taken from this environment so when I
got thrusted back in after prison I took
off ripping and running it was it was
the it was like I never left the streets
I jumped right back into smoking crack
and and
panhandling women and and uh
the lifestyle was great you had to love
it you know it just there was nothing
really that um
at that time that I I could uh I could
ask for anymore anymore you know and um
when I when I got up when I stepped off
that bus in Rhode Island I was actually
broke and I didn't have my flip-flop
shoes no more I had a pair of sandals
because I don't know where I left them
in Georgia when I got I almost missed
the bus going back and going back to
Rhode Island because I was out smoking
crack with some cheesehead and uh
you know in the back alley with some
broad trying to get get some head in the
back out here but while smoking crack
you know
um
just thinking about the David it brings
back these memories of like damn that
was fun but but damn look at where I I
I'm right now you know
and um walking into this this place here
to come do this this thing here I see
all the life forms and the the deadness
out there
and it's crazy because like you know I'm
part of that life out there
you know there was actually a point in
time where I actually lived two
different lives like I would be one way
this way at night time and then during
the day or certain days a week I'd be
this way and I'd be that way I'd be like
uh the the educated type suit and tie
you know no trouble at all because I had
finally met with um you know someone
and then
I I'd go like I said on this side of
town I'd be this person I'm easy over
here
and I'm if I'm on this side of town I'm
Mr Joe small with the suit like not even
a suit you know just dressed up casual
and and and living living the the family
life until
um I went out on a bench one night and
smoked crack for like five days straight
and I decided to rob a bowling alley
I don't know what I was thinking one of
those still some pins and some balls or
whatever and uh the lady I lady was nice
enough to let me use the phone because
the Payphone was broken and she decided
to proceed to count money behind the
counter and anybody who smokes crack
before knows that when you're feeding or
you're jonesing for that next hit and
you'll do anything and everything just
to get that next fix and I'll tell you
what I
I was standing in front of her and she
had the hand money in her hand like this
and I just said I hate to do this and I
snatched the money I bolt it out and
I'll tell you what the lady was fierce
she uh
she held on tight
and then I I reached back I hauled off
and I hit her in her mouth after about
three or four times
of uh begging her to let the money go
please just let it go and she wouldn't
so you know I hauled back and I hit it
with a right hook you know she's like
all the money you know and a couple of
her teeth too
because I I told you let the money go
you won't listen and then
um jumped into the car and proceed to
take off and
both I went straight to the dealer
to buy crack
and spend the next three days smoking
crack inside of a little room with no
windows and no air conditioning in the
back alley of woodsocket Rhode Island
somewhere it was crazy
um
those days there though they they that
all that did for me was
put me into prison
a lot more of my younger early years
you know uh
we're around 22 23
I caught a three year three and a half
year bid in a state of Rhode Island
and
prison became my life for the next I I
would say at least
four or five years
and then I caught while on while I'm I
made parole finally and now while out on
parole I'd proceeded to rob a
convenience store
um with a knife by the way and I would
have gone not even a gun what a knife
that was probably about this big
probably no bigger no bigger than this
you know and I held it up to the clerks
count I said hey let me get the [__]
money and and she pulled the drawer out
and she handed me the drawer and I
proceeded to run down the street with
the drawer and while they left the trail
of money all the way to my doorstep and
that's how the police found me the next
day because there was dollar bills and
quarters and nickels and dimes that let
the trail all the way down around the
corners of my house while I was out on
parole
um I woke up to two Johnston police
officers didn't know what we talk about
hey Mr so-and-so please won't you come
with us we we've been looking for you
for the last such and such hours you
know
um
in prison I I
you know I I didn't really use drugs in
prison
um I didn't get it because people people
would say oh well you use them on the
streets right now use them in the jail
or maybe at one point in time while I'm
in jail I would like to go ahead and try
to maybe better myself for the future
for my future
and and uh you know
um
seen a lot of things that happened in
prison I've sold drugs in prison
um I I spent about six months in the
shoe
on a whole or solitary confinement
whatever you call it
um
because you know I I was I was active
and uh
I was told to go ahead and I was
supposed to dispose of somebody on the
yard and
you know
um
as I proceeded to go ahead and
and
take care of the deed that I was
supposed to be taking care of I was I
was caught by
uh the correctional officers and I was
I was I wasn't I was actually
waiting to be charged outside the prison
but fortunately for me they didn't do
that and had no ideas were added to my
sentence I didn't um the plot was as
they say was foiled because I think I
was I was ratted out most likely and it
was probably it was I won't say probably
it was definitely somebody from my own
clique
you know and from now day four right
then and there I learned that um that
you can't even trust your own people
that you ride with you know
so I went out for I took everything I
went Renegade and I decided I was gonna
do whatever the [__] I wanted to do when
I wanted to do it and how I want to do
it and [__] a superior or whoever else
was over me I was my own um General
alone Sergeant I was on current
Lieutenant whatever you want to call it
um
you know
and I lived that way for many years many
many more years
um
probably right up until the time
I uh I moved to California you know
I've been out of prison now for I don't
believe me wrong I've been in uh jail
um
but I've been out of prison per se for
about
crap I don't even know what year is it
three 23.
yeah see outside it's been about seven
years
since I've been in prison
um
you know and all I've been doing is
living living the life I thought was the
life
now
people always ask me well how do I get
here to California Okay so
I was dating a female now I moved from
Rhode Island to Maine to the state of
Maine
thinking the geographical change we're
going to go ahead and do it for me
and all that did was told me that that
no matter where you go
there's always crack there's always
alcohol and it's always marijuana
and
there's always people who do these
things they're just different it takes
you a little bit longer to get to it
than you would be in the city because
Maine and Casco Maine and the Waterville
Maine uh the towns are small and
unpopulated really
um you know
I'm not saying one place is hotter than
the next and I'm not saying that one
place is softer than the next but you
know I
I've definitely smoked some crack with
some moose you know
um
so when I when I came to California I
was like when I was just let me back up
a little bit I was presented with the
opportunity to come to California
because I was fortunate enough to be
dating a woman who had insurance
medical insurance where
um
they would pay you uh well excuse me
they did
they would
let you come to California and
um go to rehab out here now for me
growing up as a kid
the only thing I knew about California
is what you saw in the movies the big
Hollywood Sign uh Rodeo Drive Beverly
Hills
um
you know like the Crips and the Bloods
and
the gang members and the people who
would tell you they would like oh don't
go over here don't go over there don't
walk on this side don't wear this color
over here the winds come over there you
know and for me personally I don't
really give a [__] I already got a damn
color I want to because that's who I am
I'm Eric I'm easy you know what I'm
saying
um
and when I first got here and I told
people my nickname
um because I've had several of them
since I've been here
I had a few females call me uh cash app
I mean if anybody's heard this song the
box from from the rapper Richie uh
whatever his name is
um they would understand why why they
call them females call me cash app
um
you know
I came to California
in December of 21st of 2017
and I was at a place out in Lagoon
Alicia Viejo
called Laguna treatment hospital I was
there for two weeks and I ended up going
to a program called Hotel California by
the Sea and when I heard that [__] I
said damn is it really true that they
have a hotel California oh yeah
and um I proceeded to try to live this
sober life in the righteous life and the
right life
um
but all I I figured out and found out
was that whether you're using or you're
not using
people are still the same no matter
where you go
if they want to be nice they're going to
be nice if not they're going to not be
nice
you know
um me
personally
um
I was sold for about
probably about the first 20 months I was
here in California
and I even works for a rehab one thing
that I didn't do though was change the
way I perceived of women because
um I still had
a couple couple women on the wings and I
would you know get I guess you could say
I was some type of gigolo maybe no I
don't want to say Gigolo because giggly
makes it sound dirty you know what I
mean
I was a man who liked women you know
and
um
I uh actually got married while I was
out here in California
I'm no longer with my wife uh because
when I relapsed she didn't know how to
take it and uh
you know she she gave me a chance to
have the chance of the chance but I
didn't want to hear that I wanted to go
smoke crack so the day I realized I can
I can remember the day I relapsed I was
in my Mercedes and I was riding down
Hoover Avenue
[Music]
in LA
for about a good 45 minutes to an hour
and I was waiting for the right person
to pop her head out and sure enough
some black chick
who I knew smoked crack
came popping out outside of walking I
rolled up on I was like hey can you get
me some crack
and um
she said possibly but I can also get you
some
Crystal and I said well what the [__] is
that
I don't is that methamphetamines I don't
[__] I don't mess with math no no not me
and I
held that for that that uh perception of
it until for a good for a few for a few
months like you know and then like they
say the Curiosity Kills the cat you know
what I mean and one day I was sitting on
uh because I like because it's funny
if you see a meth user and a crack user
they hate each other in the sense of the
drug that they use because one smoking
crack and the other smoking meth and
it's funny because they'll be like oh
you smoke crack and then I'll be like ew
you smoke meth
the only difference between my drug and
your drug is the price difference
because they both got [__] and it's just
gonna kill us either way and I still
have all my teeth do you
and they'll be like yeah they'll give
you that look like oh screw you [__] you
whatever and um
uh
so
I remember the night I first I first
took my first hit of um methamphetamines
they say Never Say Never
because
um
even though you say never
because never is forever
I'll tell you and and uh
I asked this guy this this
um his name was uh Tommy
and um I was kind of hitting on his
girlfriend
a few days prize it is and I didn't know
that they had were going out
because she didn't she didn't tell me
that they were but anyways I I remember
sitting in the um was sitting in his car
in the in the North Court parking lot
and he's loading his um
oil burner
uh
and I'm like hey what is that what is
what's how does how does that work what
do you do he says well if you take this
and you
you hold it over the flame and you twist
it ten and two I said damn am I driving
a car
he says no dick you go ahead and you
just hold it down let the blast heat up
and it'll melt down and then you just
suck in the smoking I I did ten and two
and I put the flame under it and then
the bottom of the bowl got all black he
said oh no what are you doing stop stop
stop you're doing it wrong I said well
what do you expect this is the first
time I've ever smoked nothing in my life
bro I'm not a professional
and I found the new I found a new love
you know
um
you know I'm not a I'm not a person who
who likes will discriminate against
drugs because
I love to love to party and get high you
know uh
so he'll he proceeds to explain to me
that you can also snort this this um
it's not methamphetamines
and if anybody who's done method of
enemies when you snort methamphetamines
the burn is something unreal all of this
feels like it's just like on fire and
your eye starts to Twitch and you you
the eye mucus just proceeds to drizzle
out your eye you're like
oh my God and for me I love it you know
um
I um
so now here I am running around
California
over in this Indiana area Anaheim in a
crime because we like as we like to call
it
um smoking crack and methamphetamines
waiting for my heart to bust you know
and it was crazy and I did that for
pretty much the rest of the remainder of
my up until the this present day
um
I actually like I said I don't smoke
crack anymore though uh the reason being
is because
um
a couple years back
I uh
I bought a um
a half half a bowl of cocaine off my
dealer and I went to my motel room and
proceeded to cook up the cocaine and in
the crack form and I did the I did this
hit and all of a sudden I felt really
sick I started sweating I was dizzy
I couldn't walk I started throwing up
and I said what the hell
so I'm thinking well maybe it's
something I ate or whatever the case
might be so I I threw that away and I
proceeded to cook some more up and same
thing happened
and uh
come to find out it was it was laced
with fentanyl
and um
what that did was it killed the desire
and the taste for it in my in my my mind
and in my mouth and in my blood
to where I didn't even want to do it
anymore
like I would get crack and I would take
a hit and it would tighten my chest up
in a bag of like post-traumatic stress
disorder over the fact that I almost I
could have died you know
um so I put the crack down and I went
full force with the methamphetamines
um I'm not a fetty user I don't do
Fentanyl I don't do heroin I drink
but with the Beth and at the time
cocaine or crack cocaine it would Mellow
Me Out And even me out into an even Keel
to where I could feel a little bit of
normalcy you know
um I do suffer from mental illness I am
duly diagnosed I uh I suffer from PTSD
anxiety and um bipolar a manic and I am
very very impulsive when I get into my
manic stations
I do not think about the consequences
until it is time to think about the
consequences and when I do
it's too late because I don't already
did it you know what I mean
um
people ask me how I survive uh to this
day I I uh
all right so people think that
okay let's let's I I'm still trying to
figure this out in my head because
it's okay for a woman to go and walk the
Boulevard and to get into a car with a
guy and trick with this guy take his
money
and get out and encode it and have money
and live off of this you know I've I've
dealt with several women I still do deal
with several women who um
who are escorts per se or blade Walkers
we call them
um
and
they it I don't get where people can say
okay well because I have what I would
call I call maybe Sugar Mama or a female
who's my girlfriend
um who would take care of me you know
um people say well why don't you get a
real job you're a man
[__] this is 2023 nobody gives a
crap where you live where you make your
money from
the only thing that anybody cares about
is how much money can they get from you
you know what I mean and
um
I get by any way I can in any shape form
or fashion that I can
um
there are things that I've done that I
probably
wouldn't say over
an interview and it's probably some that
I would you know
um
I think one of the worst things that
I've ever done was was uh probably
walk up into someone's house in the
middle of the night and
you know um
when they caught me in their living room
I I panicked
and
uh
you know I haven't been caught for this
so I won't say exactly where it was and
at what time in my lifetime it was
but um
you know this just doing doing something
like this is new is is it's kind of it's
kind of um
next time my first time you know uh but
um
yeah like
like
today is Thursday night
okay
uh once I'm done here I'm probably going
to jump into uh Uber or whatever it is
go back to where I'm from I'm going
straight to the Tap House if you don't
know what a Tap House is it's a place
where they have these machines they call
Fish machines and and Bird Machines and
little spin Jacks and pot of gold and
it's like a mini underground Casino you
know and and I love it I um
I am
I consider myself a professional Gambler
while Semi-Pro will say you know
um especially when it comes to playing
cards
uh I am a very Avid poker player um
baccarat player uh
Blackjack but my passion is poker
poker women and money that's my that's
one of my my passions right there those
are the three one of the those are three
of the three things that I love the most
you know what I mean not specifically in
that order but
you know
um
I was being dealing with a bunch of
different women
um all my life I was fortunate to love
not to catch some type of sexual
transmitted disease up until I moved to
California
and then
the first time I I realized or I went
and got checked it was
horrendous the the first time I caught
the clap they say
and it was I went to go to the bathroom
and it felt like razor blades were
coming through my hole of my dick like
it was like
I was begging for it to stop it was so
bad I didn't even want to pee okay
anybody tell you that it is different
they're a [__] liar they lie to you
and they're just saying that so you
don't feel
I don't know they're lying to you if
they say it's not as bad as they say it
is
um
I'm a person who likes to
I gotta make sure
um I look meticiously I'm worse than a
woman sometimes when it's time to get
ready to go out
um my clothes got to be ironed my shoes
have to be
cleaned and I have to it's so bad that I
have matching shoelaces to go with my
outfits
um
today is just a down day uh
you know I'm I'm in La for the first
time you know in a little bit you know I
came out here to
to do this this year and probably go see
uh one of my street sisters later on
whatever
um
she's a who uh you know I want to say
this anybody who says that a man and a
woman can't be friends without sleeping
with each other is a liar
you know because I can count on two
hands how many women I haven't slept
with all my best friends
um
don't get me wrong one of the first
things I tell a woman is hey you're a
grown woman I'm a grown man if it
happens C'est La Vie you know what I
mean
um
I learned
that there's a way to
get a buy with a woman you don't have to
beat them
to get their respect
you know
um
I learned that most see a lot of guys
out here a lot of the streets even when
I was living in Florida would hate me
because
here I am watching them beat their women
down the street and as they're coming
off the block
I come step in like hey you know what
how you doing and you tell them you look
nice today you know you uh I love you
the way your hair looks today
um you know sometimes women want to hear
that you know what I mean they they
don't want to hear you look like a [__]
a [__] a hoe or whatever it is
they they want to hear the compliment
you know and then and that's my end
right there you know
I might not be my end anymore so
hopefully but I mean um
you don't have to
smack a woman because she she's a dollar
short of what she's supposed to make a
day you know you tell her hey you know
what just make it back tomorrow
you know I'm saying I think that anytime
you put the fear into any type of person
you get no respect
I'd rather have respect than I'd rather
have someone respect me than fear me
even though putting fear into somebody
is a good feeling sometimes
it's still not going to get you what you
want are you uh or the the results that
you're looking for because the person
who fears you will be the first one to
stab you in your back when you're not
looking because they're scared that you
might do that to them
you know a person who respects you is
going to respect the fact that hey he's
in charge and he's the boss of he knows
what he's talking about so I'm going to
go ahead and listen to them
you know
um
California's been the uh
uh
not the Limelight that I thought it was
you know what I mean yes this Hollywood
is the sign
and there's a Boulevard
and then there's
Skid Row
there's
no one would ever think that outside of
Walt Disney
land
that you'd have
three people sleeping on a on a bus
bench and walking in clothes that they
look like they've been had on for about
six weeks at a time and they haven't
showered in about three months and I I
was messing with my niece the other day
and well that a few months back and I
said
she was like Uncle Larry that was easy
um
I was uh I was I was California are you
you were by Disneyland I said yeah I
said I just watched Mickey and Goofy
shoot it out over Daisy Duck
as a you know
and like
um
it's crazy you because like like I've
been to Disneyland so I'm like I'm
inside Disneyland it's like oh look at
the Splendor of a business and it's like
just the whole pleasure of fun
and then you go outside of Disneyland
and you walk through the gates back to
the population of the streets and you're
like ew
really
this is where Disneyland is and
and for people who don't live in
California
Anaheim is humongous
so to put Disneyland in the middle of
Anaheim
it's crazy
you know
um
we have a joke that like why'd you come
up to California I came out here to live
to California Dream
I mean who doesn't want to be homeless
and and and and you know I mean who
wants to who doesn't want to be living
in the car or very crazy you know what
I'm saying living on the streets and
smoking drugs and and doing it this is
the dream
everybody wanted to be an actor right
this is my audition to be an actor you
know what I'm saying because call me up
I'm ready anytime that dream wants to
fall into my lap and say hey guess what
no you're here you know but uh
I won't say California has been the
peaches and creams of my life right now
um I'm I fortunately I'm going through
some hardships
but you know what I look at those things
like
as a test this is this is my my way of
my high power saying uh
yo let's see if you can get by this
right now you know what I mean let's
even get through this whether this I
don't know see what the next stage of
the storm has for you
um
you know I'm I'm I'm I've been sitting
here probably for the last 45 minutes
now maybe an hour now and I know there's
a lot of things in there that people are
probably saying hmm but what about this
or how was it like this or what did you
do when you were doing this you know and
um
who knows maybe one day I could I could
share those things with people you know
um one of the things that I I will say
this though I saved and people believe
me don't believe me when I say this I've
been here in California for five years
I've already saved 40 people's lives
off of Fentanyl
you know
um
I don't I I I'm not a
uh
I'm gonna know another type of guy I
just I like to get it done
sometimes I'll procrastinate a little
bit
you know
[Music]
um
and and I I feel as if maybe
certain aspects of my life having been
highlighted and signed on and
um
you know and and
who knows maybe I can uh
[__] I would of other people and and
they can learn from my experiences and
uh because I've I've seen friends
come and go I've seen friends make it
and get out the life and have families
now and I see and I've buried a bunch of
friends
I know in my own world I'm the [__] and
can't nobody [__] with easy you know
what I'm saying and uh
that's how I get down
you know so all right easy thank you so
much for sharing the story
um I appreciate it I appreciate the time
you know if anything or
anybody has a question
I'll be more than glad to do it again
yeah maybe we will all right thanks man